[Music]
running into an invisible wall is one of
the most annoying things that can happen
in an open world game but such
boundaries don't always have to be so
boring and obvious here are 10 of the
coolest weirdest almost over-the-top
methods open-world games have used to
keep players contained number 10 the
Elder Scrolls online a swarm of piranhas
despite initial appearances the world of
Tamriel does have its limits whilst
oblivion and Skyrim simply showed a
message on screen telling you to go back
the other way the Elder Scrolls online
takes a slightly snappier approach and
in that you get devoured by piranhas if
you swim too far off the coast it's kind
of nasty number 9 gothic an electric
dome from biting piranhas to piranha
bytes the German developer known for
making an unforgiving alternative to the
Elder Scrolls games in its own series
gothic I am NOT interested in who you
are the first gothic game encased its
prison world in a giant dome forcefield
as a part of the story which also
happened to function nicely as an
electrical barrier I can be near number
eight far cry to a sudden malaria attack
famous for being one of the few
first-person shooters that beat you down
at every opportunity far cry 2 extended
this philosophy to the edges of its open
savanna causing you to suffer a sudden
and intense malaria attack if you stray
too far off the beaten track collapsing
into the fetal position isn't exactly
the standard shooter power fantasy but
in Far Cry 2 you take what you get
number 7 World of Warcraft the guardian
of Blizzard World of Warcraft entices
players to venture off and explore its
colorful nooks and crannies but for
areas that weren't actually built for
players Blizzard needed a high-level
enemy to keep them out this was the
guardian of Blizzard a massive elemental
golem that could kill anyone in one hit
and it could be spawned by GM's
elsewhere if anyone was making a ruckus
number 6 Grand Theft Auto for an instant
6 star wanted level Grand Theft Auto 4
divided Liberty City into a series of
islands closing them off from one
another with police roadblocks
major bridges but there's always another
way around especially if you're not
opposed to going for a swim
however passing the block' results in an
instant six star wanted level with
police shutting down the city until the
offending Explorer is brought to justice
number five Unreal Tournament 2004 the
ion cannon but bigger maps and a lot of
vehicles to drive around in them Unreal
Tournament 2004 needed a way to keep
players boxed into its arena levels that
its predecessor didn't have so it took
last year's super weapon the ion cannon
and made its orbiting satellite
automatically lock on and vaporize any
players who double jump outside the maps
boundaries
personally I'd have just taken - then
with a flat cannon but each to their own
number for Serious Sam 3 BF a a giant
sand worm the Serious Sam series is
known for its expansive levels but the
third entry did away with the boxed
canyons and walled plazas of the
previous games in favour of a completely
open desert so it's only appropriate
that a gigantic sand worm pops up and
swallows anyone who spies a mirage and
goes off wondering if this would you can
there'd be a dick joke somewhere in here
number three Just Cause two the road to
nowhere heading to a certain boundary in
Just Cause twos islands of Pinal reveals
just why developers need to keep players
boxed in here the world simply ends its
like someone has taken a buzzsaw to the
geometry unfortunately pronounced
drivers don't seem to realize this and
will drive off the edge forever like
some kind of road to nowhere
number two Motocross Madness an
invisible bike Canon the wide-open stunt
for ease of Motocross Madness were
surrounded by near vertical cliffs but
thanks to 1998 wonky driving physics you
could will be your way straight up them
now the developers thought ahead and
caused any clever rider to really launch
back into the level by way of a giant
invisible Canon qs flat sound in three
one number one crisis shark attack and
battleship crisis takes the top spot for
having more than one way to kill its
wandering players if you maximum jump
off the islands white shores and maximum
swim out into the depths you're
eventually gonna get eaten by a shark
but if you get smart and dodged this guy
on a boat
the North Korean battleships on the
horizon will sink you with a
heat-seeking torpedo not even a nano
suits maximum armor is going to deflect
one of those